I have a dream that's all I need
[Music]
I made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey guys huh
today is another unboxing video here on
the LM model lifestyle and the sponsors
are the classy company called sirata so
we got some jewelry today we got some
watches we got some bracelets we go
well let me just show you what we got
[Music]
alright here we are we got four boxes
over here so let's check out the first
one
wow that's pretty nice Arata wow that's
pretty nice Sarat so one small box and
one big one Wow let's see first one
always a ring it's got a line on it so
cool let me just take my wedding ring
off here oh yes this is quite classy and
nice
[Music]
next up let's have a look
Wow cool these are two bangles we got
two silver bangles oh let's put it on
let's have a look
oh yes loose classy
[Music]
nice these are gonna go really well with
my clothes they look really
sophisticated as well and that's why I
love it
the ring and these two bracelets so far
looks really awesome
Sarala thank you guys so much for
sending this out to me awesome
let's check out the next one the black
one see
[Music]
all right these boxes all look the same
they're the same size it looked like
that
all right the first one is a bangle
looks really good looks glossy
[Music]
just put it on oh yeah it looks pretty
neat very very nice very classy well
done guys the next one let's check it
out another one it's pretty nice but
look it looks a little bit different
here well let's put it on
yeah pretty nice all right
this is so much fun let's try the next
one
let's have a look what is this Wow this
is a anchor wow so cool so cool I love
this anchor bracelet I love fishing I
left the water so this is I'm gonna wear
this a lot all right here we go and next
one let's check it out this is the last
one from these four boxes so let's have
a look
oh it's another anchor bracelet I just
said I loved it right and now there's
another one and this one is brown this
one he's pretty cool alright now I think
the only ones left and the watches so
let's have a look alright here's the two
watches not so far I am really impressed
by the boxing it just looks very very
classy well done sir ah to all of the
box this looks very classy now let's
check out the watches
all right so it comes with some of the
instructions and care of what you have
to do let's check it out
nice very nice very nice let's open it
up oh that is what you see first it's so
cool this packaging is amazing look at
that Wow so this is the sapphire watch
the Academy white crock as you can see
there let's take it off check it out it
actually fits pretty well with the
outfit that I have on but this is a
really nice watch my kids
[Music]
all right let's try the next one
[Music]
Wow this is really nice
it says here's got genuine Italian
leather which is really awesome as well
on the other side it says sirata over
here pretty stylish man I like it
let's try it on here we go it's pretty
awesome right it's very similar to the
other one the only difference is this
one got a black croc there in the middle
but both of them are really really
stylish they look classy and I'm gonna
probably heard them a lot
[Music]
you want to check them out out of there
links for you in the video description
so you can check it out if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
and we'll go talk soon Cheers
[Music]
you